can tires be sexy pirelli think so for
almost every year since nineteen
sixty-four the tire maker has put
together one of the most exclusive
calendars in the world and to celebrate
its 50th edition peretti surprised
everyone by digging out and
never-before-seen 1986 black-and-white
calendar shot by Helmut Newton we had in
our attitudes photos of her minuta that
never came up because the year in which
made the photos there was another
calendar rain and luckily enough the
gates of the 86 the calendar of Newton
are the same page of 2014 it was shot in
Tuscany and Monte Carlo and features
former supermodels Betty Prado and
Antonia dell'arte while this may be a
calendar from 1986 for the second year
running they're breaking with pirelli
tradition the models they've got their
clothes on how do they feel about seeing
their younger selves reincarnated when I
was in the Gaza station with the very
poor dress and I have my prayers almost
coming out of from the dress you know
that's the very same show over the past
50 years the calf as it's become known
has seen the likes of Heidi Klum and
Kate Moss strip off for some of the
world's most famous photographers while
it may cost a lot to produce the Pirelli
it's not a profit-making exercise a bit
of glamour in the brand I think it's
part of our communication we appear in
every corner of the world
Ellie Brandon is a result we want to
have a link to something that is quality
wise in line for brother it might be
free but you won't find this on every
mechanics wall usually reserved for the
rich and famous pirelli are very picky
about who gets one traditionally
producing no more than 20,000 copies a
year